[Music]
back in the gold rush days of the mid
1800s
there was a desperate need to deliver
stuff on the east coast where everything
was established
to the new wild west colonies over in
california
mail could take up to 25 days to make it
from coast to coast
and you were never even sure if your
mail would arrive
after all mail couriers had to trek
through the new frontier with plenty of
ways to die
which really puts into perspective the
frustration we feel today for having to
wait an entire day or two to get our
amazon order
today our delivery ecosystem looks a
little different
and if we plot all of our different
modes of delivery stuff onto a chart
from mega container ships to giant cargo
planes to our smaller and smaller
vehicles from semi trucks to delivery
trucks to vans to cars and bikes for
things like door dash and uber eats
it's not that hard to see where things
are headed for one of the most important
parts of our economy
just like what happened with electric
scooters you'd say well
we had planes on charter 25 years ago
through netjets we eventually had
smaller planes on charter then we had
buses on charter then we had
limousines on charter then we had cars
on charter then we had cheaper cars on
charter than we were pooling cars then
we had bicycles
i mean you literally did not have to be
as smart as you
to take that trail of breadcrumbs and
say well what's the quantum of transport
that's smaller than a bicycle
but greater than your feet
so what's a quantum of delivery that's
smaller than a car and bike
but greater than your fee and faster and
potentially cheaper than both
drones which has led to one of the next
great races in engineering
a multi-billion dollar race not for
space but for the skies
and with the us's new ruling to allow
commercial drones to fly over humans and
at night
this emerging industry is set to explode
here's everything you need to know and
to profit from
the great drone wars using drones to
deliver your groceries it will soon be a
reality in fayetteville i don't know if
i'm ready for that
amazon's new drones could be ready to
take flight
in the race to dominate the skies
google's project wing
now poised to bring deliveries to your
driveway walmart's bigger goal is to one
day see millions of items delivered by
drones
to your doorstep this is ehong's testing
headquarters in guangzhou
and this is a passenger drone that
they're developing it could even be
flying in the skies in the next couple
of months for them it's like a moon race
yeah but for the companies that deliver
everything to you
this could have a massive impact quickly
yeah things could really start to move
quickly now you'll start seeing swarms
of drones it could be the
the dr the drone swarm that is that's
pretty serious
imagine that flying over your city
imagine at night time
all those little bees flying over your
head and
unrestricted or restricted but far less
restricted
if you're the problem solver type that
wants to profit off of revolutionary
tech industries like drones but you
don't know where to start
that's where today's proud video sponsor
comes in brilliant
brilliant is a problem-solving website
and app that gives you the perfect
introduction you need for industries
like drones ai quantum computing and
more
their 60 plus courses are all crafted by
award-winning teachers researchers and
professionals from mit
caltech duke microsoft google and more
where instead of sitting through boring
lectures or textbooks
you actively put your brain through the
paces for topics like classical
mechanics
electricity and magnetism machine
learning and a ton more
the faster and more effectively you
learn the faster you can participate in
these cutting edge fields before the
opportunities pass by
join over 8 million people learning on
brilliant by going to brilliant.org
jake tran to sign up for free and the
first 200 people that go to that link
will get 20
off the annual premium subscription
that's brilliant.org jaytram with the
link in the video description
imagine a day when with a few taps on
your phone you order a burger
but instead of some plaid delivering it
to your door by car
the restaurant places your food on a
drone that drone takes off from the
restaurant's launch pad
it flies over to you in a relatively
straight line way faster than driving
through traffic
a retractable door on your roof opens up
its landing pad
the drone drops off your burger in a box
and a tiny elevator brings it down to
you for
consumption this is the dream of
delivery drones
a dream that has largely remained a
fantasy sets the inception of commercial
drones all the way back in 2006.
that all changed recently with a new faa
ruling starting early 2021
companies will be able to operate their
drones around people and at night with
some regulations
with the biggest points being the drone
can't be over 55 pounds
the drone needs to broadcast a remote id
basically a license plate brock has to
be a radio at all times
which will include the drone serial
number or a unique flight id number
the latitude longitude altitude the
control station emergency status and
time reference
drones will also have to have
anti-collision lights that can be seen
for three miles to be able to fly at
night
and drone operators will have to have
their pilot certificate on them while
flying
like a driver's license these rules will
go into effect early 2021
and drone manufacturers will have 18
months to start making drones with
remote id
with this newfound freedom with
regulations the fastest growing
transportation segment that's already
had billions of venture dollars poured
into it
just got that much more exciting
companies like amazon walmart and even
alphabet have been testing delivery
drones for a few years now
but this new ruling is probably going to
set them free to fight for who can be
first the first company to really roll
this out to the mass market
if you can be the first company to make
a viable drone delivery system
not only are you going to have the
fastest delivery but your company is
going to get the most press the most
watermouth and the most hype
and for smaller startups the most
venture capital dollars
from 2008 to 2019 venture capitalists
dumped over 4 billion dollars into the
industry
vc money has slowed down in 2020 but
with this new ruling i wouldn't suspect
that to continue for very long
but perhaps most importantly the first
movers who get this tech working are
going to have a massive head start to
scoop up market share
and to cement their throne at the top of
the hill we talk about the first movers
advantage a lot on this channel
and this latest arms race in drones is
no different
but this progress in the u.s market has
some respectable competition
around the same time china also
announced a new ruling regulating
commercial drones
the specification for express delivery
service by unmanned aircraft
very catchy with the biggest points
being lending delivery drones have a
higher payload capacity of 75 pounds
so they can deliver bigger and more
things with a max speed of around 60
miles per hour
with the biggest advantage being that
one of their tech giants jd.com
have already been making drone
deliveries for a few years now with the
latest being using flying drones and
self-driving cars to deliver goods
during the pandemic
when their usual transport lines were
disrupted the company has also already
made seven types of delivery drones that
have had over 6
600 flight hours on over 100 routes ever
since october 2015
while u.s companies have kind of been
sucking their thumbs waiting for
regulators
china is not too far ahead but they do
have a decent head start
let's take a look at some of the most
notable examples in the us
amazon already has their prime era
program and beta testing right now
where they're promising small deliveries
in 30 minutes or less via their new
drone
they're working with a handful of
customers in the uk as we speak and will
be slowly expanding their reach as time
goes on
the person actually marks a little
territory in their backyard with an
amazon bullseye so that the drone knows
where to land
supposedly this has a sense and a void
technology
built in whether it's flying or landing
so it won't land on anything that you
really care about
ups is taking a slightly different
approach they've partnered with cvs and
a hospital to target the health care
industry
and instead of launching the drone from
a warehouse they have their drones
deployed from the top of their trucks to
deliver medicine
reducing the delivery time to minutes
for important things like medicine
and test results google's parent company
alphabet have their own drone startup
called wing
where they're kind of like a ups or
fedex service but with drones that
target small business owners
wing offers them a way to deliver small
goods to their local customers
exactly when they need it within 6 miles
in 6 minutes
what's crazy is that they've already
been operating relatively under the
radar and have delivered tens of
thousands of items in the u.s
australia and finland for the drone it
flies to the center
sends down a container the sender puts
the package in
the drone pulls it back up and sends it
down to the customer
a lot of energy is spent lifting off and
touching down so this probably saves
them a lot of juice
google's drones carry packages beneath
their belly lowering them to people's
yards with a tether
while it hovers a safe distance above
valkyrie is offering a solution to the
last step in the drone delivery process
where the drone is going to land and
take off from and how to secure the
packages for the right person
think of it like amazon's hub lockers
but for drones instead of delivery
drivers
if you want to send something you put it
in your designated locked mailbox
the mailbox's elevator system brings it
up to the top when the drone arrives
it aligns the package before attaching
it to the drone
then the drone is off receiving packages
is the same process but in reverse
the drone drops off the package at the
top
and the elevator brings it down into the
person's locked mailbox
[Music]
i was doing research on electric
airplanes recently and the main reason
they haven't taken off
no pun intended is because of one simple
limitation
battery capacity it takes too many
batteries which adds too much weight to
make any meaningful flight with
passengers or cargo
drones run into a similar problem but to
a lesser degree
as of right now drone delivery is still
more expensive than traditional
transport
but drones today are still way cheaper
than they were five years ago
on top of that companies haven't had
much incentive to innovate in this field
since it was difficult to deliver near
people and at night
with this recent change in the faa
stance and the heat coming from china
i personally don't expect drones to be
more expensive than other means of
transport for very long
once it passes that threshold and
companies see that they're losing more
money by sticking with other delivery
methods
it would be all up from there aside from
the cost of the actual drone
there's still a lot of logistics to
figure out how is the aerospace going to
be managed between all the different
companies
what's going to be the backlash when a
drone eventually crashes and damages
property or hurt someone
but i have a feeling that if the profit
margins are there entrepreneurs will
have no problem solving these issues
oh my boss would have my ass crazy
get lost you now naysayers will always
mock new ideas like these as
unrealistic that this could never happen
that there are starving children in
africa and you greedy bastards want even
faster delivery
don't we have a social responsibility to
take care of the needy first
well one this has already been used to
deliver medical supplies and two
if i told you in the early 1700s that
one day
we're gonna have these magical tubes
that run all over buildings
where you can stick in a small canister
of urgent mail and it will be sucked up
and set throughout an office or multiple
buildings in a matter of seconds and oh
yeah
it's going to be powered by air you
would look at me in the same way people
look at today's radical ideas
and yet pneumatic tubes were widely
adopted and are still used today in some
places
just like how it took smartphones a few
generations to be good enough for the
majority of people to adopt them
so we've had smartphones as a new form
factor
happen and they were expensive but they
only took
i would say like three to four years
before
most people we're looking to get a
smartphone
delivery drones will go through the same
thing we're practically in the first
generation of delivery drones
so it's no longer a question of whether
or not it's possible that's already been
proven
the real question is when will we reach
the point where this becomes profitable
when this becomes practical
is it the second generation the third
the fourth time will tell
but once that happens the innovators the
open minded will make money
and the naysayers will be left behind
sucking their thumb while they get drone
deliveries themselves
if you want to be a part of those
innovators pushing the world forward
and getting paid very handsomely for it
why not check this out
it's a lesson on the physics and
mechanics of drones specifically the
drone battery problem
this lesson is from brilliant the
problem-solving website and app that
lets you dive deeper into topics like
these in a fun approachable way
this drone lesson is from their main
course on classical mechanics
which is filled with 49 interactive
lessons just like this one
when you join brilliant this is what it
looks like you get to cherry pick the
individual topics you want to learn
or if you want a more guided approach
you can choose from one of their popular
learning paths
like applied computer science
probability statistics
advance and applied science where
brilliant recommends you which courses
to take in which order to get the best
understanding of a broad field
for me i think it's smart to have a
general understanding of a ton of
different fields and industries
so i can see what the next major trends
are and potentially jump on them
so i really like that i can just log on
to brilliant and know that i'm getting a
great baseline
understanding on all these different
cutting edge topics to see if i want to
pursue them further
it's a one stop shop so if you want to
do the same or check out that drone
lesson
join over 8 million people learning on
brilliant by going to brilliant.org
jake trying to sign up for free and the
first 200 people that go to that link
will get 20
off the annual premium subscription
that's brilliant.org
jake tran with the link in the video
description
do you guys like this style of videos
where we go over upcoming trends in the
business world that you guys can
potentially profit off of
if you guys do you can let me know by
tapping that like button down below that
way i can get a gauge on how much
interest you guys have
and it's also very helpful for the
youtube algorithm speaking of youtube if
you are new to this channel we go over
the most thought provoking
controversial provocative stuff in the
world of business
every single week in this form of video
essays so if you want more of them for
free
every single week make sure you
subscribe down below after you click
that like button
if you want only the best business memes
behind the scenes stuff
day in the life kind of stuff me
complaining about stuff you can follow
me on instagram
jaketrend.io we have a ton of fun over
there if you want to be the first to see
these videos you can sign up for the
email notification squad with the link
below that way you get emails every
single time a new video posts
you can support this channel financially
by checking out today's sponsor that is
going to wrap up today's video stay
dangerous out there
and i will see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you